I heard about you didn't think you were real your
guilts have become your reason hate is useless
i will come for my great prize if you want
the batman here is something that can helpyou
i have a stake in this world and
it's time i started fighting for it
you've fulfilled your promise
I spenta lot of time trying to divide us
I need to bring us together
and make this right
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new justice league snyder cut trailer for the
batman dark side martian manhunter stuff you also
may have seen today zack snyder posted what is
basically the entire story breakdown for justice
league two in justice league three because there
were going to be a couple sequels three movies
total so now we know exactly what was going
to happen in all the sequels so i'll talk a
little bit about that during this video too
but there are pages and pages of his story if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos i'll be doing a bunch of videos
for the snyder cut when it releases it's going to
be over four hours long so there's going to be
a whole lot to talk about in a couple weeks but
this is meant to be a very batman centric justice
league snyder cut trailer with him standing on the
gargoyle in a very frank miller batman inspired
scene with a lightning behind him lighting up the
background and you get a bunch of voice over from
the different characters cyborg meeting batman for
the first time not totally believing that he's
real i believe we heard that line of dialogue
in all the early trailers for the theatrical cut
years ago and i think that batman's answer to that
was something like i'm real when it's useful
just talking about the myth of batman when the
events of the movie take place because batman had
been dormant for so long when the events of man
of steel and batman v superman pick up with zod
in the kryptonians attack being his big call to
action to come back then there's a different
scene of him standing on top of that frank
miller looking batman tank looking out over the
city skyline at the bat signal with a bunch more
voiceover and dialogue from a bunch of different
characters starting with alfred talking about his
guilt a lot of batman's motivation comes from his
guilt then wonder woman talking to him about hate
being useless in our first official preview of
darkseid's voice in the movie i will come for
my great prize it's not clear when that line is
happening in the movie when he's speaking it if
someone else is hearing it in a vision or if it's
being spoken in the flashbacks there were reports
a long time ago about a cyborg scene where he's
interfacing with the mother box and sees a vision
of darkseid like a cosmic zoom call where the
mother box connects him to darkseid briefly
the great prize being all three of the
mother boxes not just the one mother box
the whole thing with those three mother boxes
is that they're unique in that dark side can't
just replace them by having three new ones built
or he would have done it thousands of years ago
there are a lot of conflicting details between
the theatrical cuts story changes and why that
is but i believe it has something to do with the
anti-life equation and that plays a much bigger
role in the snyder cut storyline so it might just
be that these three mother boxes when they combine
are the key to him unlocking the anti-life
equation then you have the martian manhunter
line where he says i have a stake in this
world it's time i started fighting for it
you have jared leto's joker laugh from either
the snyder cut or suicide squad it's kind of
hard to tell because it sounds exactly like it's
sampled from suicide squad but it could have been
re-recorded for justice league because we know
about all the extra joker scenes then alfred is
saying you've fulfilled your promise i believe
the promise he's referring to is the promise he
made to his parents when he became batman and
put the cape and cowl on then the scene from
the end of the movie was superman in his black
suit helping batman up to the top of the ledge
where they look out over the battlefield after
they defeated steppenwolf in their assembling
as the justice league just waiting for batman
ship to come pick them up with batman's voice
over talking about how he spent a lot of time
trying to divide them but now they have to come
together he's referring to the events of batman v
superman then you hear lex luthor's voice saying
if you want the batman here's something that
can help you and here's the thing about lex
luthor in the snyder cut in the justice league
sequels that zack snyder had originally planned
thanks to twitter user accidentally dan there's
a special justice league snyder cut exhibit in
zack snyder totally on purpose not an accident
posted the entire story breakdown for all the
justice league sequels that details what all the
characters are doing and what's going on with the
injustice league and lex luthor so because there's
so much story here i should probably do like a
whole separate video about this when i do more
justice league snyder cut breakdown videos in a
couple weeks but i'll read this one page that goes
over the story outline for justice league 2 and
it says 2a so obviously this is just part of the
story for justice league 2. and as you can see it
involves a lot of lex luthor putting together his
own quote-unquote league like we saw at the end
of the theatrical cut so obviously theatrical cut
very different story but some of the elements from
the snyder cuts story survived so i believe this
is zack snyder's handwriting here on this it says
although originally pitched is one film we believe
the character arcs of our heroes and villains
along with the epic battle with darkseid which
unites the league the world and the entire dc
universe warrants two films so it sounds like
he's trying to argue with the studio when this
is happening for why they need multiple films when
the studio was trying to turn it from three movies
to two and then from two movies to one movie so
i'm guessing that these are literally documents
that he gave to the studio executives
at warner brothers to help convince them
to give him more sequels he then goes on to say
however this does not mean that you have two films
centered on darkseid's invasion rather justice
league two would be a very grounded personal
and character-driven film that would follow
the justice league both together and separately
as they mend old wounds on the road to becoming
better and stronger heroes then get this while
lex luthor recruits a league of his own made up of
revenge driven villains introduced in the hero's
solo films dr maru during the original wonder
woman movie she was dr poison if that wasn't clear
leonard snart captain cold from the flash movie
which originally was supposed to come out in 2018
remember this document was written back in 2016
2017 i guess ormond black manta introduced in
the aquaman movie which was also supposed to come
out in 2018 in the riddler which would have been
introduced during ben affleck's version of the
batman movie funny that the riddler was such a
big character during ben affleck's version of the
batman and he's also the main villain as far as we
know in the robert pattinson batman movie these
villains would link all of the dc films together
like empire strikes back in the last harry
potter film justice league 2 would end with
a cliffhanger revealing at the end of the film
lex and his league are connected to darkseid then
flash forwarding five years into the future where
darkseid has taken earth so you have lex luthor in
his injustice league colluding with darkseid they
kind of did a version of that storyline during the
justice league apocalypse war animated film then
he goes on to describe the hero's arcs through
justice league 2. with lois's health the back from
the dead superman would learn to become clark kent
again feeling more human than ever as he and lois
start a family wonder woman would reconnect with
the amazons her mother and eventually become their
new queen and basically end the amazon's practice
as isolationist warriors and connect them with
the outside world again aquaman with the help of
mira would bring the seven kingdoms together seven
kingdoms of atlantis they kind of dealt with that
during the aquaman movie becoming the one true
king building a new alliance between the oceans
in the surface world the flash would free himself
from the past releasing his father from prison
with cyborg's help and learning how to master his
time travel abilities literally becoming able to
be in two places at once i believe we're going to
see him do something like this during the justice
league snyder cut some version of this ability
cyborg would evolve into the modern day god of
the digital age and into a human once again
and batman will ultimately sacrifice his life
for these unlikely friends and the woman he loves
leaving behind a legacy that will never truly die
the woman that they're referring to the woman that
batman supposedly loves there was a report from
inside warner brothers studio that at one point
zack snyder wanted to have a lois lane romance
with batman while superman was dead like he winds
up falling in love with her but then superman
comes back so lois lane winds up going back to
superman so you have this weird superman batman
lois lane love triangle for just a brief hot
second before batman winds up sacrificing himself
i don't know how palatable fans would have found
that aspect of the story but obviously there's
so much other stuff here to unpack but that's
basically how the sequels were meant to leave
the characters at the end before they obviously
go off to more sequels in their own solo films
now he was just calling these justice leagues part
2 and 2a so i don't know if there would have been
a 2b maybe that would have been justice league 3
because this would have been way more than just
justice league 2. you guys can let me know what
you think about that storyline i might talk more
about this when i do more breakdown videos for the
actual movie because the way zack snyder explains
it his justice league snyder cut even though he's
adding all this stuff in it's over four hours long
it ends on a massive cliffhanger but he says the
studio right now has no interest in making his
sequels there's way more stuff that was revealed
but i will break down more of these sequels
story when i do more videos for this what'll
happen though is because we're only a couple
weeks away from the movie coming out is we'll
get a couple more trailers like this probably
centered around the other justice league
heroes like we'll get a superman version
of this batman trailer we'll get a wonder
woman version a flash version cyborg version
the movie is being released on the 18th i don't
know if it's going to be a midnight release or if
it's going to be during the middle of the morning
but whenever that comes i'll do a video that day
and then the next day after that on friday
falcon and winter soldier episode 1 is going
to be released so it'll be a really busy week
for me for videos to get through all that stuff
it's going to be really exciting as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you should
see all that stuff when i post it but if you
have any big questions or any big easter eggs
that you spotted in this that i didn't mention in
the video just write them below in the comments
my Wandavision finale video will be next that'll
post friday morning there'll be a whole bunch of
videos for that this weekend as well while
you wait for everything click here for all
my Wandavision finale predictions and click
here for that brand new thor 4 love and thunder
first look video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!